bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle semaine du 7 8 lactu le journal
de la rédaction et voici les titres de
ce lundi Benoît monte tout juste nommé à
l'éducation vient également de rentrer
au conseil municipal de Trappes il siège
dans la majorité du socialiste Guy
Malandain mais s'apprête à découvrir
l'opposition au sein de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin face
aux difficultés des étudiants à trouver
un job pour cet été Yvelines Information
Jeunesse organise pour la première fois
un grand forum en mairie de Versailles
ce mercredi nous allons en parler avec
l'une des responsables d'ygi l'ancien
cinéma Gaumont à Montigny le Bretonneux
est ouvert il a été transformé en
bowling 15 pistes bientôt inaugurés
visite guidée à suivre
l'image du jour tout d'abord c'est le
lycée de la plaine de naufles attrape
l'établissement figurant en première
place du classement établie par le
quotidien Le Parisien sur les
établissements et les plus performants
principales explication un taux de
réussite au bac en forte progression de
61% en 2010 à 84% long dernier mais
surtout un dispositif d'accompagnement
des élèves qui permet d'éviter le
redoublement en seconde
nous restons attrape où se dérouler
vendredi soir le premier conseil
municipal visant à installer les
nouveaux élus guimalandin reconduit dans
ses fonctions il bénéficie pour débuter
cette nouvelle mandature d'un ministre
dans ses rangs Benoît Hamon et siègera
bien voilà la ville mais aussi à
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines en marge de son poste à
l'éducation au gouvernement claire
Cambier et Elodie moine
Benoît mont tout juste élu ministre de
l'éducation de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche un nouveau poste dans
un gouvernement remanié suite à la vague
bleue qui a défaire les sur la France et
dans les Yvelines lors des municipales
et pour lui cette défaite de la gauche
s'explique par une forte abstention si
l'électorat de gauche c'est abstenu
c'est qu'il ne se reconnaissait plus
tout à fait dans les cas dans les
résultats
de la politique du gouvernement
conséquence de quoi il fallait apporter
une inflexion sous la forme d'un nouveau
gouvernement et surtout d'une
réorientation de la politique européenne
d'une inflexion sociale de la politique
du gouvernement ce qui me semble
absolument indispensable une nouvelle
orientation politique mais il l'affirme
l'une de ses priorités l'application de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires au-delà
de ce nouveau poste Benoît Hamon en dose
donc le rôle de conseiller municipal à
Trappes vendredi dernier il s'yé au
premier conseil municipal de la Ville
trappes restent aux mains du maire
socialiste sortant guimalandin la
dorénavant une des 18 communes seulement
toujours à gauche dans le département en
5e position sur la liste municipales PS
le conseiller obtient par la même
occasion un poste d'élus au sein de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de rôle locaux
qu'il compte donc remplir pleinement moi
je reste de toute façon un élu de ce
territoire au service des citoyens de ce
territoire ministre ou pas ministre
d'ailleurs ça changera rien le jour où
je ne le serai plus je garderai le même
état d'esprit un rôle d'opposition
cependant au sein de la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a basculé
à droite pour la première fois depuis sa
création
un ministre sanguin Conseil Municipal
que peut apporter Benoît Hamon à la
ville de Trappes c'est notre question du
jour vos réponses au micro de Jonathan
willemann
pas forcément non je pense pas
non
il a une certaine notoriété mais bon je
pense pas qu'il ou alors il faudrait
qu'il s'investisse un peu plus dans la
vie de la ville ben moi déjà rien n'a
changé ça fait plus rien plus de 10 ans
je pense pas qu'il pourrait changer
quelque chose
Monsieur Sylvie on espère bien je sais
pas est-ce qu'il aura le temps encore de
s'occuper de la ville de Trappes avec
ces nouvelles fonctions j'en sais rien
je sais pas je peux pas vous dire
j'espère mais on verra moi je pense que
c'est un homme comme tous les autres des
ministres et qu'il est capable de le
faire absolument pas déjà une je me
demande qu'est-ce qu'il fait à
l'éducation nationale ça c'est la
première des choses monsieur Hamon il
s'est présenté il a promis pas mal de
choses ici au trappiste et en plus aux
jeunes dont il n'a pas tenu sa parole
monsieur Hamon je vois pas qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ça plutôt au niveau de la
région que il faudra influencer quoi mon
avis je vais souvent pensé mais
malheureusement quand on voit les gros
que les gros travaux qu'on sollicite ils
n'avance pour même quand la gauche est
au coup elle a dit gauche et au pouvoir
toujours et ce week-end d'autres
conseils municipaux ont été installés
c'est le cas à Maurepas tout d'abord
Grégory garestier pour l'UMP a pris la
place de Georges Mougeot une page se
tourne dans cette ville détenue par la
gauche depuis 30 ans Valérie Pécresse
chef de fil de la formation a fait le
déplacement et lui avec 25 votes des
conseillers sur 33 possibles le nouveau
maire à longuement été ovationné
réaction à suivre lors d'une de nos
prochaines éditions et puis à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux à présent autre
conseil municipal Alexandra Rosetti
succède donc Homère sortant Alexis
billet tu MP que les électeurs n'ont pas
choisi de reconduire 15 voix d'écart
entre l'ancien premier magistrat de la
ville et son ancien adjointe lors de son
discours samedi elle a appelé l'ensemble
des élus à servir l'intérêt des
vicinoise et Davis chinois quant à
alexibia-t-il parle d'irrégularité même
si l'accepte le résultat il devrait le
contester en déposant un recours il se
dit néanmoins prêt à apporter son
expérience à la nouvelle équipe
je suis extrêmement ému évidemment je
même un peu du mal à réaliser en fait
mais voilà beaucoup beaucoup d'émotions
et puis aussi comme je l'ai dit dans mon
discours je mesure le poids de la
responsabilité tout simplement donc
voilà et je suis impatient de mettre au
travail je travaillerai toujours dans le
respect des gens et ça c'est un
engagement et je crois que je l'ai
toujours prouvé par le passé toute façon
donc j'aimerais que voilà calmer
peut-être les inquiétudes que certains
pourraient avoir suite à forcément dans
une campagne il y a beaucoup de choses
qui courent voilà et puis à
Mantes-la-Ville enfin le seul maire
Front national de l'Île-de-France c'est
aussi installé la tête de la ville
vendredi soir dans un climat électrique
des opposants à la formation d'extrême
droite ont été arrêtés en marge de cette
cérémonie d'investiture nous en
parlerons demain dans notre premier
édition du 7 8 politique sur TVfil 78 à
18h30 nouvelle émission à suivre sur
notre antenne l'invité sera Philippe
Chevrier le responsable départemental du
Front national
vendredi les personnels administratifs
du terme de grande instance de
Versailles était dans la rue pour
manifester et grogner il réclame
aujourd'hui plus de moyens pour exercer
une justice à la hauteur de ses
ambitions c'est ce qu'ils disent Olivier
Maniscalco
140 fonctionnaires en colère devant le
tribunal de grande instance de
Versailles après un courrier remis à
Christiane Taubira ministre de la
Justice le 3 février dernier la grande
s'est accentuée ce vendredi 4 avril le
personnel administratif du TGI réclame
une amélioration des conditions de
travail une juste reconnaissance
salariale et un recrutement d'urgence le
retard en matière de conseil des
prud'hommes des dossiers c'est un délai
qui est pas respectable disons donc pour
le juste ici pour les usagers le délai
est trop long les personnes attendent le
justiciables attendent des délais de
décision plus courtes que ça il faudrait
effectivement de l'ordre un peu plus
tard dans l'après-midi les cinq
organisations syndicales étaient reçues
par la garde des sceaux une discussion
qu'ils ont qualifiée de franche et
directe mais si le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu et bien là des réponses sont
encore à attendre notamment en raison du
remaniement ministériel des discussions
doivent se tenir ce vendredi 11 avril la
veille une mobilisation nationale est
attendue dans les différents tribunaux
de grande instance
on passe à l'invité de ce lundi pour
débuter la semaine je reçois Lucile
Guérin bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes en charge de
l'opération journée job à Versailles qui
se tiendra mercredi sous l'impulsion
d'Yvelines informations jeunesse
première question aujourd'hui il est
encore possible de trouver un boulot
pour l'été lorsqu'on est en étudiant
malgré le contexte de crise et malgré la
concurrence des salariés des chômeurs
des demandeurs d'emploi qui eux aussi
veulent du travail et forcément ils
doivent se concurrencer c'est maintenant
que les jeunes doivent s'en préoccuper
justement commencer à rechercher
d'éventuelles recruteurs commencer à
préparer leur CV leur lettre de
motivation justement pour postuler
postuler en vue de trouver un petit job
d'été pour voilà jouer en juillet-août
une concurrence qui existe véritable
aussi avec les demandeurs d'emploi
aujourd'hui il faut que les les jeunes
pour même pour les boulots étudiants
soit vraiment de des professionnels et
qu'ils envoient leur demande de la même
manière encore plus aujourd'hui que par
le passé comme comment demandeur
d'emploi lambda alors après nous on se
rend compte voilà que c'est important de
déposer CV lettre de motivation comme un
recrutement normal je dirais voilà la
concurrence elle est là dans le sens où
on remarque que depuis à peu près deux
ans c'est beaucoup plus compliqué pour
nous même de trouver des offres de job
d'été à proposer aux jeunes déjà parce
que les entreprises s'organisent
différemment il y a un auteurs
pour ces jeunes quelle est la motivation
première pour un jeune est-ce que c'est
toujours peut-être que c'était quand
même le cas par le passé plus pour
arrondir les fins de moi aussi pour les
loisirs pour préparer les vacances le
mois suivant par exemple si on travaille
en juillet aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
aussi plus qu'avant une nécessité
bien sûr la dimension de l'argent se
faire de l'argent de poche préparer ses
vacances c'est important également aussi
le fait de se faire de l'expérience ça
revient beaucoup les jeunes qui viennent
nous voir voilà ils ont pas envie de ils
ont deux mois de vacances voir plus et
ils se voient pas rester deux mois
forcément en vacances qui viennent vous
voir et justement c'est quoi leur
motivation et vous en parle et vous
disent il faut à tout prix que je trouve
du travail parce que parce que à la
rentrée j'ai les études à payer alors il
y a ça et puis il y a aussi parfois il y
a la pression des parents également qui
fait que bah voilà les jeunes doivent se
financer aussi leurs études et du coup
un petit boulot étudiant ça peut ça peut
déboucher ensuite sur un poste à plus
long terme une fois qu'on a fini ses
études ou en tout cas ça fait de
l'expérience pour le CV là aussi c'est
important ça peut permettre d'être
valorisé dans un CV pour plus tard et on
boit certains jeunes qui postulent juste
pour l'été et au final ça se transforme
en job étudiant tout le reste de l'année
et ça leur fait un petit apport
financier qui est pas négligeable alors
ce forum pour les jobs d'été ce sera la
mairie de Versailles ce mercredi 9 avril
de 14h à 18h comme on va se dérouler cet
événement il y a beaucoup de partenaires
vous avez travaillé avec les bureaux
pour information des différentes
communes plus le centre en formation
jeunesse comment ça va se dérouler c'est
déjà premier arrivé premier servi ou pas
forcément alors cette année c'est une
première c'est que on ne le fait pas
tout seul on a co-organisé avec d'autres
points Information Jeunesse point et
Bureau information jeunesse des Yvelines
donc Vélizy Le Chesnay Jouy-en-Josas et
Fontenay-le-Fleury alors les jeunes
voilà faut qu'il soit présent le mieux
c'est de venir avec un petit CV déjà
pour arriver pouvoir présenter leurs
candidature au potentiel recruteurs sur
place il y aura des recruteurs présents
dans différents secteurs d'activités on
aura Monoprix par exemple pour la
branche commère on aura réseau 78
Trianon Palace pour tout ce qui va être
restauration en termes de services à la
personne on a altidum et le conseil
général des Yvelines avec le programme
Yvelines étudiant senior qui sera
présent également dans l'animation avec
l'UCPA lifac voilà
qui reviennent le plus souvent pendant
l'été c'est dans la restauration
justement hôtellerie ou
il y a des choses auxquelles on ne pense
pas oui l'hôtellerie il y a pas mal de
postes il y a également tout ce qui va
être haute et hôtesse d'accueil en
entreprise l'animation aussi c'est un
secteur qui est bien
qui propose pas mal d'offres et
également on aura le j'oublier de citer
le château de Versailles qui sera
présent pour la branche spectacle et qui
recrute pas mal de jeunes justement
pendant cette période là vous nous dites
il faut mieux arriver avec un cv pour
autant vous aider à les rédactions des
CV sur place aussi sur place voilà il y
aura des ateliers cv
en français mais aussi en anglais parce
que voilà il y aura le réseau Europe
Direct la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines qui sera présent sur place au
forum et qui pourra proposer des jobs
justement à l'étranger quels sont les
emplois qu'on peut faire à l'étranger
parce que ça doit être très prisé
j'imagine oui alors il y a des postes
comme en France dans la restauration
dans la vente
et puis également tout ce qui va être
jeune fille au pair même si pendant la
période de l'été c'est moins évident de
trouver sur sur cette période là mais il
peut y avoir des offres encore plus un
avantage ensuite sur le CV que d'avoir à
travailler un petit peu à l'étranger ne
serait-ce que pendant les vacances quel
conseil on peut donner aux jeunes qui
vont venir au-delà d'avoir déjà un petit
peu travaillé sur son CV ça l'aide de
motivation devenir comme pour un emploi
pourquoi pour un entretien d'embauche
c'est vrai que ça va être voilà le
premier contact qui vont avoir avec
l'employeur donc c'est toujours
important de voilà d'avoir une bonne
présentation de montrer aussi surtout sa
motivation en termes de conseil je
dirais que
faut aussi être clair sur les périodes à
laquelle on est disponible souvent les
recruteurs pour une ou deux semaines ça
risque d'être un petit peu juste souvent
ils vont préférer recruter pour
quelqu'un qui est disponible un mois
voire deux mois combien de postes
éventuellement disponibles vous avez une
idée de ce que vous allez pouvoir
proposer alors il y aura un certain
nombre de postes en termes de chiffres
je pourrais pas vous dire exactement
chaque année ça se réduit un petit peu
voilà mais après c'est aussi aux jeunes
de faire des candidatures aussi
spontanées de leur côté de faire jouer
leur réseau les entreprises de leurs
parents ça marche encore pour pour
certains jeunes pour donner des conseils
à ces étudiants qui nous regardent même
ce sont des conseils qui vont forcément
de qui sont forcément de bon sens pour
autant il y a aussi des droits pour un
jeune qui travaille comme pour n'importe
quel autre salarié quand on rentre dans
le monde du travail on a des protections
de la même manière il y a des oreilles
de travail de la même manière il faut
aussi le rappeler parce que quelquefois
ça existe tout de même il y a des
employeurs qui forcément ne sont pas
très regardants sur ces questions là oui
tout à fait la législation est pas la
même pour un jeune qui qui sera mineur
voilà on a le droit de travailler à
partir de 16 ans mais ils n'ont pas le
droit de travailler en même nombre même
nombre d'heures que une personne majeure
toutes ces informations là les jeunes
ils peuvent le retrouver sur un guide
que le CIDJ a édité trouver un job qui
pourront trouver également le jour du
forum qu'on diffusera et ils peuvent
également trouver une version
informatique sur notre site
www.jobonstock.fr site sur lequel on
diffuse des annonces de Job voilà pour
les étudiants tout au long de l'année
pour ceux qui auraient raté le coach ou
qui vont rater le coach de ce mercredi
encore une possibilité de venir vous
voir vous allez toujours aider à faire
des CV sur
au site divine d'informations jeunesse
tout à fait tout au long de l'année on
est présent voilà pour les aider dans la
rédaction de leur CV de leur lettre de
motivation leur donner des conseils leur
distribuer de la documentation voilà et
puis également il y aura pas que ce
forum là comme on est un réseau
départemental il y en aura un petit peu
partout dans le département
et toutes les dates sont indiquées aussi
sur notre site internet je m'en stock.fr
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour nous parler de cette
initiative d'Evelyne Information
Jeunesse job d'été cette opération qui
se déroule à Versailles ce sera mercredi
merci à vous merci on passe à présent au
sport et ça y est les joueuses
d'Élancourt sont devenus championne de
France de Pro B face au Club Athlétique
Mayenne et une victoire qui ouvre les
portes de la ProA retour sur cette
prestation mémorable dans une ambiance
des grands sauts Olivier Maniscalco
pour cette rencontre face au Club
Athlétique Mayennais un parfum de pro à
flotte dans le palais des sports
d'Élancourt ce soir le cet été reçoit le
premier du championnat de probedam et
pour les deux équipes la victoire est
synonyme d'accession au plus haut niveau
français l'entraîneur Franck Saulnier ne
citron pas et aligné d'entrée sa
meilleure joueuse et vaodorova ne fait
d'ailleurs qu'une bouchée d'Océane et
BNR trois 7 à 0
et l'Empire mène la danse mais le
prochain match s'annonce compliqué
Audrey arrive à peine 15 ans affronte
l'expérimenté d'ibao l'international
junior a beau se démener elle multiplie
les fautes techniques et s'inclines en
trois manches dans le troisième match
Yann l'avantage à Élancourt grâce à une
partie globalement maîtrisée et
l'encourt mène alors 2-1 et le quatrième
match entre deux Rova et dibao qui sont
clairement la poudre
la rencontre propose au public bouillant
une belle intensité à cette partoule la
fin de la troisième manche est un
tournant la Slovaque en difficulté est
menée 11 12 la suite de l'histoire se
passe de commentaires
evaodorovar remporte finalement 4 ou 7 à
1 à sa confrontation un match quelle est
allé chercher au mental
mais je pense qu'avec avec l'expérience
que j'ai même si c'est une joueuse très
très expérimentée aussi en face mais
avec encouragement avec la volonté
surtout parce que je voulais vraiment
absolument gagner et je pense que avec
la volonté j'ai gagné
le travail en quatre mots je suis face à
Océane et l'encours et sacré champion de
France de Pro B à trois journées de la
fin une satisfaction pour fonctionner au
regard du potentiel de l'équipe et de la
bonne saison de ses joueuses même si
l'entraîneur élancourtois Satan à un
tout autre niveau l'an prochain en
première division ça n'a rien à voir ça
va vraiment dire il y a un fossé il y a
un très gros fossé entre cette division
là et celle du dessus l'année prochaine
on va voir des supers matchs avec un
super niveau de jeu parce que le
championnat de France est un des
meilleurs championnats d'Europe avec
l'Allemagne nous on essaiera de se
maintenir déjà parce que on arrive on va
être les petits poussins de de la
division on va essayer d'avoir un
objectif de déjà de maintien
puis on va se bagarrer quoi les trois
derniers matchs sans enjeu vont
permettre de débuter la préparation de
la saison prochaine et de faire tourner
l'effectif un effectif qui verra au
moins arriver une nouvelle joueuse la
saison prochaine
ont quitté l'encours je vous propose de
vous rendre à Montigny le Bretonneux
dans les locaux de l'ancien cinéma
Gaumont qui ont été transformés en
bowling 15 pistes installées
inauguration prévue le 9 avril visite
guidée
les amateurs de bowling vont retrouver
leurs habitudes installés depuis 2007 à
Skywest à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
l'établissement avait quitté le centre
en janvier 2013 pour prendre possession
en novembre dernier de ces nouveaux
locaux à l'espace Saint-Quentin dans les
anciennes salles du cinéma Gaumont 5
mois de travaux ont été nécessaires pour
tout aménager ça a été un gros
investissement ça a été surtout très dur
parce que il a fallu descendre tout le
matériel dans les sous-sols dans les
sous-sols des anciens cinéma et ça s'est
fait à la main et ça a été un peu épique
reste maintenant à retrouver une
clientèle par rapport à la fréquentation
enregistrée Skywest le chiffre a été
divisé par deux mais le gérant espère
fidéliser rapidement de nouveaux
amateurs grâce à ses 15 pistes ces 8
billards et à la multiplication des
propositions d'animation nous avons un
espace de réception je dirais les zones
de consommation une salle de réunion qui
sont plus vastes et donc on a plus de
possibilités de recevoir des clients de
façon conviviale et agréable on deux
grandes sites de clientèle chez
bowlingstar c'est d'une part la famille
et d'autre part les entreprises et pour
recevoir aussi bien les entreprises que
la famille lorsqu'ils sont en groupe il
nous fallait de l'espace qu'on n'avait
pas forcément et qu'on a maintenant le
lieu emploi 6 salariés Robert Capet
envisage prochainement une autre
embauche le bowling fait partie d'un
groupe national qui dispose de 20
établissements en France
pour terminer ce journal nous revenons
sur l'actualité politique vendredi le
premier conseil municipal visant à
installer les élus attrapent ces tenues
guimalandin a été reconduit dans ses
fonctions et le bénéficie pour débuter
cette nouvelle mandature d'un ministre
dans ces rang Benoît Hamon siègera donc
bien dans la ville et mais aussi à
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines en marge de son poste au
gouvernement claire Cambier et le
dis-moi
Benoît monte ou juste élu ministre de
l'éducation de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche un nouveau poste dans
un gouvernement remanié suite à la vague
bleue qui a défaire les sur la France et
dans les Yvelines lors des municipales
et pour lui cette défaite de la gauche
s'explique par une forte abstention si
l'électorat de gauche c'est obtenu c'est
qu'il ne se reconnaissait plus tout à
fait dans les cas dans les résultats
de la politique du gouvernement
conséquence de quoi il fallait apporter
une inflexion sous la forme d'un nouveau
gouvernement et surtout d'une
réorientation de la politique européenne
d'une inflexion sociale de la politique
du gouvernement ce qui me semble
absolument indispensable une nouvelle
orientation politique mais il l'affirme
l'une de ses priorités l'application de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires au-delà
de ce nouveau poste Benoît Hamon en dose
donc le rôle de conseiller municipal à
trappe vendredi dernier il siégé au
premier conseil municipal de la Ville
trappes restent aux mains du maire
socialiste sortant Guy Malandain la
dorénavant une des 18 communes seulement
toujours à gauche dans le département en
cinquième position sur la municipale PS
le conseiller obtient par la même
occasion un poste d'élus au sein de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines deux rôles
locaux qu'il compte donc remplir
pleinement moi je reste de toute façon
un élu de ce territoire au service des
citoyens de ce territoire ministre pas
ministre d'ailleurs ça changera rien le
jour où je ne le serai plus je garderai
le même état d'esprit un rôle
d'opposition cependant au sein de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a basculé
à droite pour la première fois depuis sa
création
prochaine édition du 7 8 l'actu demain à
18h toujours en direct nous ferons le
tour de l'actualité locale excellente
soirée